[Music]
it's time for et's late-night roundup
your quick catch-up to all the best TV
scoop after dark night is there anything
bigger than the Sports Illustrated
swimsuit issue not for me Kate Upton is
the 2017 sports illustrated swimsuit
edition covergirl the big news and sexy
pics were revealed on Tuesdays jimmy
kimmel live is that really a swimsuit
that you're wearing cuz it seems just
like a hammock they got corn sure that's
just a row over on The Tonight Show
kendall Jenner put modeling on the back
burner to step behind the camera as a
photographer her subject host Jimmy
Fallon Jimmy not only posed at his desk
he posed on his desk
[Applause]
shailene woodley gush to seth meyers
about meeting Malia Obama she was there
she was at Sundance to to hear what the
Chairman from Sandy and rock had to say
and some of the water protectors had to
say and it was neat to see her be
invested personally and separately from
her family in these causes and Lars from
Metallica got candid with James Corden
about the band's audio issue during
their performance at Sunday's Grammys
here's what he said about lead singer
James Hetfield's reaction we got get off
stage we get back there and I haven't
seen him like that 20 years I mean he
was livid I mean he's he's aged yes but
it's really well and he's the pretty
chill guy but the first five or ten
minutes in that dressing room was not a
lot of fun
[Music]
you